هذا هو مركز التحكم في المهمة هيوستن
فتحة قفل غرفة معادلة الضغط مفتوحة ،
ومن النادر أن يرتدي رائد فضاء
أوروبي بدلة فضاء روسية ويقوم
بالسير في الفضاء مع رائد فضاء خارج
محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
لكن الأمر أكثر غرابة بالنظر إلى الحرب
الدائرة في أوكرانيا.  بضع مئات من الأميال
أدناه خاصة وأن رائد الفضاء
أوليج أرتيمييف هو واحد من الصور الثلاثة التي تم
التقاطها هنا
قبل أسابيع قليلة مع أعلام
منطقتين روسيتين محتلتين في
أوكرانيا ، والرائد الآخر هو سامانثا
كريستوفريتي مع وكالة الفضاء الأوروبية
أو إس إيه ، كل شيء على ما يرام
سامانثا  وقتك للتألق
أعتقد أن سامانثا تقوم بهذا المشي في الفضاء
مع أوليج هل تعلم أن البصريات
ليست الأفضل ولكنها في الفضاء ،
إنه عمل يحتاج إلى إنجازه ،
رائد فضاء ناسا السابق سكوت كيلي أمضى ما يقرب من ثلاثة
أشهر في الفضاء مع كريستا فيريتي
مرة أخرى في عام 2015.
تتمثل مهمتها في هذا السير في الفضاء في
مواصلة تنشيط الذراع الروبوتية الأوروبية
المرتبطة بالجزء الروسي
من  وجهت المحطة نفس
الذراع الآلية في الرئيس السابق لوكالة الفضاء
الروسية إلى رواد الفضاء بالتوقف عن الاستخدام في
وقت سابق من هذا الشهر بعد أن
قتلت أوروبا مشروعًا فضائيًا منفصلاً مع
روسيا بسبب اعتراضات على الحرب في
أوكرانيا ،
تمت إزالة ديميتري روجوسين كرئيس
لكون روز بعد أيام فقط  لقد كنت
سعيدًا حقًا برؤيته يذهب كيلي ،
وكان أحد أكثر منتقدي gozan صخبًا
حتى دخل في بعض المعارك على تويتر
قبل أن يحظره ريجوزين ،
هدد روجوزين مرارًا وتكرارًا بسحب روسيا
من محطة الفضاء ردًا على
عقوبات الولايات المتحدة الآن يأمل كيلي أن
يكون بديل راجوزان  سيحسّن يوري
بوريسوف علاقة روسكوزموس مع ناسا بوريسوف ،
وسيكون الآن مسؤولاً عن
الإشراف على تبادل المقاعد المتفق عليه حديثًا
بدءًا من سبتمبر
سيطلق رائدا فضاء روسيان على مركبات
فضائية أمريكية من فلوريدا بينما سيركب اثنان من
رواد الفضاء الأمريكيين
الصواريخ الروسية إلى الفضاء ،
إنها ممارسة كانت كذلك  تم القيام به في
الماضي ولكن ليس مع وجود توترات بهذا الارتفاع ،
لدي رسوم مختلطة  فيما يتعلق بهذا الأمر
، فقد نجت محطة الفضاء الدولية
من كل صراع على الأرض
لأكثر من عقدين من الزمن ، وعلى الرغم من
الحرب في أوكرانيا ، تستمر هذه الشراكة غير المتوقعة
في الفضاء
، حيث يعمل أوروبي وروسي جنبًا إلى
جنب لمدة سبع ساعات لإنهاء المهمة ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على  عملك الشاق
كريستين فيشر سي إن إن واشنطن
بخير الآن إنه جيد